you own a a ton of domain names right
yeah i bought a bunch like how many do
you own now
or how many have you i won't count all i
mean i own hundreds and hundreds but the
ones that are
our top level primary domain names about
16.
i like words in the english language
that everybody
understands like i own emma uh frank
i own my own name i own michael.com
i also own my nickname mike.com
uh so like my personal website i've got
it on michael.com you just type
michael.com you see all the stuff about
me
uh hope yes sam go to hope.com see where
that takes you
go to hope.com yeah well actually
bitcoin is hope so if you type hope.com
you get everything there is a know about
bitcoin
i actually repath hope to all of our
resources and materials uh
speaker i i owned voice.com
and i sold it for 30 million dollars a
couple years ago that's the largest uh
naked domain sale in the history of
domain so
tell them tell the short version of that
story the story is kind of crazy i've
heard it once before but i i would
assume
sam and most people have not heard the
story of sellingvoice.com
you bought all these early on in the web
you kind of recognized oh these are
these are probably going to be valuable
to own these names there's only one you
know
there's only one owner of each of these
names you you own it and you hold it for
a really long time like over a decade
and uh at some point you decide okay
maybe we should see if
somebody wants to buy some of these so
tell the story of sellingvoice.com real
quick
well yeah we i i bought all these
domains because i thought wouldn't it be
great to own a part of the english
language i mean
owning hope or owning voice i mean
eventually there'll be a google voice so
there'll be
you know some some telco company that'll
want to launch some service and what a
great domain
on to launch on the on a word like
voice.com
so we held them a long time and and uh i
think at some point we were looking for
joint ventures we're looking to
commercialize them and we did
commercialize a bunch for example i
created a company called alarm.com
and alarm.com is now publicly traded on
nasdaq it's
like four or five billion dollar market
cap company
and and you can guess what it does it
actually integrates your home alarm into
the internet
you know and i created another company
called angel.com and we saw that for a
bit more than 100 million dollars and
that was actually a speech
interactive voice response like surrey
or alexa before
siri and alexa came along and uh
so i had voice and i was holding it and
we're looking for some kind of good
uh commercialization and someone out of
the blue
they contacted us one of the domain
brokers
and they said well you know do you want
to sell it we'll give you 150 000.
and uh and i you know i was like
someone came to me said they have 250
000 i said no so
i thought nothing of it because i just
i couldn't see the point a week later
they come back and say well they doubled
it to 300 000 i said tell them no
so a couple days later they go well the
broker's really insistent uh
and so they went to 600 000. i said no
so they said well what should you say i
said don't tell anything tell them
you know like we're not interested it's
got to be something serious
so they went to 1.2 million
i said tell them no
i said well they want to know what you
want for it
i said um well
send them a note or something and just
tell them i said it's like
it's it's the word voice in the english
language right so
it's gonna have to be something you know
north of uh i don't know i don't think i
said seven or eight
eight figures but i just said a lot of
money
um and so it went on and they doubled
again to two and a half million
and then uh and then uh
5 million and then around 10 million
then i said they said i had like 18
people in my office they're like or not
eight but eight eight people they're
like
looking at me like aren't you are you
gonna take the money it's like a lot of
money now i said
uh no send them back uh
at this point send them back an a note
pointing out that this is like
the word voice in the english language
and it's and it's
it's worth a billion dollars to the
right company
and uh they said well you're going to
give him a response i said uh
okay tell him 30 million
tell him i'll take 30 million for it
because i thought like if i didn't give
them
some number they would stop negotiating
after you know
five no's so i said tom 30 man i don't
want to sell it for 30 million i want to
sell it for 100 million or more but i
guess i'll say 30 million
so that so at that point they said well
you know they offered you
i think they upped their their offer to
like um
12 million i said tell them uh no but if
you want i'll take a meeting with them
so when it got to 12 million i said i'd
get on the phone for half an hour
so then we got on the phone and the call
started with someone saying well
how about 22 million and i said um
let me explain this is like my daughter
like i'm willing to i'm willing to like
marry her
off but only to a man that values her
more than i
value her
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i put my law in it like
no days off
on the road travel never looking back